the Asia Europe partnership it accounts
for 60% of the world's population 70% of
global trade and half of the planet's
gross domestic product the Asia Europe
meeting process is a perfect Forum to
strengthen economic cooperation enhance
political Dialogue on global and
Regional issues and deepen
Partnerships but I'm convinced more than
ever that the welfare and future of
Europe requires the stability and
economic dynamism of Asian
societies at the same time Europe
continues to be a primary export market
for Asia and the source of technological
innovation Europe Asia relations are
today more relevant than
ever and this is not just a vague
General political Declaration of
intentions this is confirmed by by the
facts facts of economic relationship and
by trade and also by increasing
political
interaction asm's beauty is its
Simplicity an open flexible Forum
allowing more than 50 Nations to engage
in an informal manner on topics of
global interest and
concern established in 1996 asm's 20th
anniversary is fast approaching and the
Forum is still growing it's an incubator
for IDE ideas a place for discussion
rather than speeches for Frank and open
dialogue with the focus on content
instead of
process this time that focus is on
promoting financial and economic
cooperation working side by side on
global challenges like climate change
and human rights as well as enhancing
dialogue between Europe and Asia the key
is connectivity promoting the free and
seamless movement of people trade
business energy and
infrastructure common security concerns
like piracy are also a theme as well as
the outpouring of solidarity between
Europe and Asia when it comes to
handling the aftermath of natural
disasters because ASM is not just about
high level meetings it brings together
members of parliament Civil Society
academics and business Representatives
that's People to People
contact